my name is johannes margarian and my
presentation topic today is classical
texture synthesis and beyond
a brief outline of my presentation is
the following we'll begin with an
introduction to texture synthesis where
i will given a definition of texture and
the problem formulation and motivation
next i'll
start with classical texture synthesis
and talk
about two of the most fundamental
texture synthesis algorithms first image
quilting for texture synthesis and
transfer by efforts at all
whose main contribution is the quilting
algorithm for patch blending and second
texture optimization by quattro at all
uh where they define a mark of random
field based similarity metric and base
their solution on
an optimization
uh problem of an energy function and
next i will segue to neural texture
synthesis and begin uh the discussion
with one of the first works in the
fields uh texture synthesis using cnns
by gate is at all
where they use
the feature space of a pre-trained
network in order to
model a texture uh and finally i will
talk about a more recent
method non-stationary texture synthesis
by joe atoll where they use generative
adversarial networks to learn to
generate
texture
output textures that are that are two
times larger than the input
finally i will provide the comparison
among these folder algorithms and visual
results and at the end i will briefly
conclude my talk
so let's begin with a texture definition
a lot of the times it's very hard to
give a strict definition of texture and
depending on the field such as computer
science mathematics or psychophysics
the definition and interpretation of the
word changes
[Music]
in general any surface structure can be
treated as texture
but a more general and more formal way
of defining texture is its structural
interpretation so texture is a spatial
variation in diverse layers of pixels
demonstrating reiterating patterns
combined with varied randomness in
quantity there are essentially four
types of textures
regular textures that imitate a regular
pattern irregular textures that are
slightly more varied than regular
textures stochastic textures that look
like
noise but with very high variance and
non-stationary textures that contain
large-scale inhomogeneous structures
the idea of texture synthesis is the
following we are given an input texture
and the goal of the synthesis algorithm
is to
generate an expanded version of the
input that is
perceptually similar to the given input
texture synthesis is a research area in
computer vision and
computer graphics and image processing
and it has many
applications in different areas such as
image editing and game development
in addition to that
ideas and concepts from texture
synthesis can be further applied to
different other research areas such as
style transfer imaging painting or image
out painting
the evaluation method
in the case of texture synthesis
algorithms is a mostly human
observation or human inspection because
most of the well-known scores
do not convey a sufficient amount of
information to assess the visual quality
of the output texture
so let's begin with image quilting image
quilting by afrosettle is a
non-parametric texture synthesis
algorithm that generates an output
texture given an input texture
so let's formally assume that we are
given an input texture i of size m by n
and
the goal is to synthesize an output
texture as in addition let's also assume
that we are given an a set of input
patches uh where each patch is of size w
uh now uh the goal of
the very naive and the basic approach to
texture synthesis is styling uh that is
we begin the synthesis procedure by
first sampling a random patch from the
given input patches uh and uh at each
step we uh
sample another random patch from the
given uh set of input patches and the
blended over the
output texture s and we do this
procedure until the whole texture s
output textures is synthesized
for some types of textures this may
already provide pretty adequate results
but if we take a look at an example we
can notice that
at the edge of the two patches
a clearly visible seam is noticeable so
we want to provide an improvement over
this procedure so we define an overlap
size o and search the patch of the given
input patches for the most similar patch
to the given patch over the overlap
region
this clearly provides an improvement
over the
very naive approach because the two
patches p i j and p i prime j prime are
similar over the overlap region
however in this case too we still have a
noticeable seam at the boundary of the
two patches the final improvement that
is suggested by the authors is the
following after finding the two similar
patches we also compute a minimum cost
path in the overlap region and use it as
a boundary during the blending procedure
if we now take a look at an example the
clearly visible scene from the middle
figure has disappeared at the bottom
now let's take a look at the whole
procedure of the algorithm so we are
given an input texture i so first we
choose the patch size and the overlap
size
then we randomly select a patch uh from
the set of input patches in order to
start the synthesis procedure
uh then at each step we search the set
of input patches to the most similar
patch
to the given patch over the overlap
region using some tolerance parameter
epsilon
epsilon is essential to introduce some
randomness in the output texture but
more information will be provided later
regarding the epsilon parameter
finally we compute a minimum cost path
in the overlap region and use it during
the blending we continued this synthesis
procedure in the raster scan order or
diagonally as it is visually represented
on the slides
now i'd like to go through each portion
of the algorithm
so let's start with patch selection so
the goal of the patch selection is the
following we are given
some
patch and the goal is to find uh the
distance between the patch and the
given input uh every patch of the given
input texture uh for that purpose we
define a matrix d where each element is
uh the msc between the given patch and
uh every patch of the given input
texture then we find the minimum
distance from the given from the
computed matrix d and uniformly select a
patch from the
uh
[Music]
from the set of input patches that has
smaller distance than the expression
that is provided on the slides
for patch selection we essentially have
two options we can either use three
based
nearest neighbor search algorithms such
as kd trees or bolt trees or we can
apply a convolution based msc
calculation which further can uh be
accelerated using fft so formally let's
assume that we are given um
a patch ps and we need to calculate uh
the most similar patch from the input
texture i if we write the msc between
the given image and the given patch in
an extended form there is a
component wherein we need to compute the
mse uh the the convolution of the given
input uh
[Music]
image using the given patch as a kernel
and at this point if we further want to
accelerate this process using the ffts
we can um
utilize the convolution theorem which
basically states that the convolution
operation in the position space is
equivalent to direct multiplication in
the frequency space
so we can use fourier transforms to
transform the given input image and the
patch to the fourier space and
apply direct multiplication in the
frequency space and use black transform
in order to get the result of the
convolution
uh
this procedure requires only a couple of
computations for the
computation of the fourier transforms
but uh and is def uh and is therefore
much cheaper than the naive approach
now let's see how a minimum boundary cut
can be computed let's formally define um
a path gamma of size uh
of length l uh as a set of uh as an
ordered set of eight connected pixels
and let's assume that we are given two
patches that are p1 and p2 that are
similar over the overlap region so first
we compute eij which is the square
distance between the two patches in the
overlap legion at position i j then we
formulate the the problem of finding a
minimum boundary cut
as an optimization problem where we need
to minimize the sum of e gamma k's where
gamma k belongs to the path
at this point we let's also note that um
the problem the optimization problem
that is presented on the slides uh
satisfies the principle of optimality
which implies that if we have an optimal
path that goes from the bottom to the
top
and if we choose a random point on that
path the path that goes from the bottom
to that point is also an optimal point
that goes from the bottom to that point
so we basically this allows us to solve
the
optimization problem uh using a dynamic
programming where we need to compute the
cumulative minimum error boundary cut
using uh the formula that is presented
on the slide it is basically a sum
of eijs and the minimum of the three
points below i j
uh at this point i would like to take a
look at the influence of each parameters
of the algorithm so we have three
parameters the patch size the overlap
size and the tolerance let's fix two of
them and take a look at the influence of
the uh
of an individual parameter so the patch
size controls the amount of information
that is propagated from the input
texture to the output texture if the
patch size is small then
there are more patches in the patch
selection process and therefore uh more
randomness is introduced in the output
texture while at the same time if the
pad size is large then large-scale
verbatim copy zones are introduced in
the output texture as it is represented
in the case when a patch size is equal
125
and next let's segue to overlap size uh
if the overlap size is small then the
risks of
creating large-scale verbatim copy zones
in the output texture decreases
while if we increase the overlap size we
can guarantee that there is a seamless
transition between the two similar
patches but if the overlap size is uh
too large then there is a risk of
garbage growing as it can be seen in the
rightmost
example when
the overlap size is equal to 0.75
finally the tolerance parameter controls
the amount of variation and randomness
that is introducing the output texture
if epsilon is small then
there is a risk of
creating large scale copies in the
output texture while if we increase the
tolerance parameter there are more
patches in the patch selection process
so the output texture is more random
and
it contains more variants
the next classical texture synthesis uh
algorithm on the menu today is texture
optimization uh texture optimization by
quattro at all is a again non-parametric
texture synthesis algorithm and it they
base their solution on the following two
assumptions let's first of all assume
that uh a texture follows uh the markov
random field property which in the case
of textures comprises locality and
stationarity locality implies that the
pixel intensity value of a given pixel
is only dependent on pixel intensity
values in its neighborhood
uh while
the stationarity assumption refers to
that that the
dependence is only is independent on the
position of the given pixel
second let's also assume that if all
neighborhoods of the output texture s
are equal to
some of the neighborhoods in the input
texture then
the
output texture s is considered as
similar to the given input texture
next we define uh we formulate the
texture synthesis procedure as an
optimization of an energy function let's
formally assume that we are given a
patch sp around pixel p of size w and we
are also given a patch ip from the input
patch that is the most similar patch to
the given uh patch sp
the texture energy over the whole output
texture s is defined as a sum of uh l2
norms between sp and ip
and
for all uh subs for all neighborhoods in
the output texture in practice we only
choose to work uh with a subset as uh
as star because it is a computationally
less expensive and
in general it is redundant to have the
all neighborhoods in the output texture
let's see how the algorithm performs so
we are given an input texture i and some
initialization of the output texture s
and we iterate the following two
procedures until convergence for each sp
we find the closest input neighborhood
ip and next we update the output texture
s
by optimizing the energy function that
was presented in the previous slide
as i mentioned we need some
initialization of the output texture as
to begin the synthesis procedure if we
are not provided with an image
initialization we randomly
assign input patches to ip and the last
question that remains since how when to
stop the optimization procedure and the
authors in this case suggest
hosting the optimization procedure when
ip stops changing
the optimization problem that was
presented in the previous slide can be
loosely treated as expectation
maximization
in the energy function we treat the
output texture as as variables while
eyepiece as parameters
then in the e-step we minimize the
texture energy function with respect to
s
and since the attached energy function
is quadratic we end up solving a system
of linear equations an interesting case
is when two patches in the output
texture s overlap namely sp and sq then
um
the in the overlap region the pixel
intensity values are drawn to the two
different input patches ip and iq and
therefore from this perspective the goal
of the e-step is to
assign the average of the corresponding
pixel intensity values from the input
texture to the
overlap region in the output texture in
the m step we minimize the texture
energy with respect to the
eyepiece
hence the parameters and this
corresponds to nearest neighbors search
that was also introducing the
image quilting algorithm and
authors implement nearest neighbors
search using kd trees
in addition to that the authors suggest
running the texture optimization
algorithm in a multi-resolution and
multi-level synthesis and the motivation
of this approach uh are the following
uh so the output uh texture
the result and the
convergence of the algorithm is
dependent on the initialization of the
output texture
in addition at the uh the patch size if
the if the patch size is small then
there is um
more variation in the output texture but
at the same time we may not capture
large scale structures and if the page
size is large then
large-scale verbatim copy zones may be
introduced in the output texture
and finally the
right source of the patch size is highly
dependent on the resolution
of the input texture
so the idea of applying multi-level and
multi-resolution synthesis is the
following we start at a very low
resolution and use different patch sizes
at each uh resolution from largest to
smallest large pet sizes help us capture
large gas structures while low uh small
pest sizes uh apply a further refinement
spread over the output texture
and at the next resolution level we use
the current resolutions output and
upsample it and use it as an
initialization to
uh to the next uh resolution level
uh this helps us avoid uh
getting stuck at that local optimum
now let's see the influence of
resolution levels on the output texture
as it can be noticed as we increase the
number of resolutions the visual quality
of the output texture increases and the
risks of garbage growing decrease as it
was the case when uh the number of
resolutions is equal to one
finally uh let's segue to uh neural
texture synthesis and begin our
discussion with a texture synthesis
using cnns by gades at all
this approach is a parametric texture
synthesis algorithm and therefore we
need to explicitly define a texture
model
the authors assume that textures are
stationary which means they they are
homogeneous and they don't contain large
scale structures
formally let's assume that we are given
an input texture i and our goal is to
synthesize an output texture i had the
texture model is computed
in the feature space of a pre-trained
vgg
the architecture of which is shown on
the right and the goal is to start from
a noise and
to start from a noise and optimize the
output texture to obtain a
uh output texture that has a similar
texture model as the given input texture
so in order to define
the texture model or the summary
statistic let's also assume that we are
given fl which is a matrix that contains
um
that contains the feature maps from
level l then formally the summary
statistics is a set of
gram matrices where each gram matrix is
an inner product between the feature
maps
from layer l
then in order to formulate the problem
as an optimization problem let's also
assume that we have we can we compute el
which is the
sum of square differences between the
gram matrices from level l between input
and output textures
and the loss function is formally then
defined uh as a weighted sum of els
now let's see how the whole algorithm
works we are given an input texture i
and some initialization of the output
texture i had
we begin by first computing the summary
statistics of the given input texture i
then we our goal is to optimize the loss
function that was presented in the
previous slide in order to obtain an
output texture i had
that has similar tests
similar summary statistic as the given
input texture let's also note at this
point that
the
gram matrices are calculated using only
convolutional or pulling layers and
therefore the output
can have arbitrary size
um in this case too we begin the out the
initialization
of the output texture
from a white noise and
the authors optimize the loss function
using lbfgs
let's also take a look at the influence
of layers that we use to calculate the
gram mattresses the name of the layer
that is shown on the slides
is the top most layers which means that
all the layer preceding layers have been
used in the calculation of the gram
mattresses
so it can be noticed that in the first
layers only the general structure of the
texture have been captured while if we
increase um
if we go deeper in the network then
um the visual quality of the output
texture improves and more details are
added to the output texture
the final
texture synthesis algorithm that we will
cover today is non-stationary texture
synthesis by joe at all
[Music]
this particular algorithm is designed to
handle non-stationary textures which
contain large-scale inhomogeneous
structures with spatial variation in
different attributes such as
color
local scale or orientation
in this approach we uh we are going to
use generative adversarial networks to
learn to generate output patches that
are two times larger than the given
input patch let's formally assume that
we are given an input example texture
and a patch from the given input texture
and uh
the goal of the generator network is to
generate an output texture that is two
times larger than the given input
texture so as uh in this case the output
texture is s of size two times w
and the goal of the discriminator
network is to classify whether the given
its input comes from the given input
example architecture or is generated by
the generator network
let's also note that we in this case we
deal with self-supervised learning
because uh the ground truth i is
directly taken from the
given input example texture the loss
function comprises of uh the adversarial
loss the l1 loss and the style loss
the other cellular loss in this case is
the main driving force while the l1 and
style losses are added to the total loss
in order to stabilize the training
reduce the artifacts and improve the
visual quality of the output texture
in this approach we need to train a
separate generator for each given input
example or texture
now let's take a look at the very
general arc architecture of the
generator network and the training
procedure
the generator network is fully
convoluted convolutional which implies
that it can take inputs of arbitrary
sizes uh particularly the given input
example texture can be given uh as an
input to the generator once it has been
trained in order to obtain a an output
texture that is two times larger than
the given input example texture
the generator network comprises of
convolutional layers and residual blocks
uh in six
in number so the residual blocks are
added to the architecture of the network
so we can go deeper in the network to
increase the receptive field of the
network and at the same time try to
avoid any potential problems we can have
during the training procedure the
receptive field at the end of the
last residual block is 106 which is very
close to the pad size w that the authors
use during the training procedure
the chaining works as follows uh we
randomly set at each iteration we
randomly select a a patch i of size 2
times w from the given input example
texture and
this i is going to serve as a ground
truth
uh next we randomly select the patch uh
w from the
from i and give it as an input to
the
to the generator the training procedure
is optimized using the adam optimizer
let's now see the influence of each loss
term on the output textures
so uh we begin with the adversarial loss
and we can notice that only the general
structure has been captured uh while as
we add the l1 and the style losses the
visual quality of the output texture
improves and
more color and details are added to the
output texture
let's also see the influence of the pad
size in this case
so the general idea here is that the
patch size should be large enough to
capture large-scale structures and
propagate it from the input texture to
the output texture
uh and this is especially essential when
we deal with non-stationary textures and
the passage should be small enough so as
we can
get
a distinct amount sufficient amount of
distinct
patches of size 2 times w to serve as
ground truth
let's now uh
go over a comparison among these four
algorithms
so the primary advantage of image
quilting texture optimization and
texture synthesis using cns is
controllability
in the case of image quilting
controllability refers to the idea that
we can modify the parameters so as to
handle most types of textures except two
non-stationary textures which cannot be
handled in three of the algorithms that
we saw today
in the case of texture optimization and
texture synthesis using cnns uh the
controllability refers to the idea that
we can modify the energy or loss
function so as to handle specific
texture cases or improve the visual
quality of the output texture
non-stationary texture synthesis can
handle all four types of textures
and and in addition to that uh
non-stationary texture synthesis can
generate very large textures if the
output texture is given a back is an
input to the generator
the speed is only an advantage in the
case of image quilting
uh while in the case of non-stationary
texture synthesis we have very fast
inference speed the training speed is uh
quite slow and another disadvantage of
non-stationary texture synthesis is that
it requires training a separate uh
generator network for each given input
example texture
let's go through some results and in
this case we can notice that the only in
the case of regular textures uh the only
algorithm that fails is nasty
is texture synthesis using cnns
in the case of irregular and stockhas
stochastic textures all four algorithms
provide satisfactory results for human
observation
and in the case of a non-stationary
textures we can notice that the only
only algorithm that has been able to
capture the non-stationarity and the
large-scale structure of the wood
is non-stationary texture synthesis
while the rest of the algorithms have
failed particularly
in the case of
texture synthesis using cnns only the
slot the style has been captured uh
while the large-scale inhomogeneous
structure of the wood hasn't been
captured by the algorithm
uh so let's also conclude
today's presentation so today i went
over uh four uh texture synthesis
algorithms uh classical and neural image
quilting is a fast and controllable
algorithm that handles regular irregular
and stochastic textures texture
optimization is a slow but controllable
algorithm and it handles all uh the same
types of textures as image quilting
uh texture synthesis using cnn's is a
slow but controllable algorithm and it
handles only irregular and stochastic
textures non-stationary texture
synthesis provides very fast inference
and it handles
all four types of textures that is a
regular irregular stochastic and
non-stationary textures
here are some references if any of you
is interested in further research
thank you for your attention
[Applause]